Taylor Swift and Joe allling call it
quits now some fans think the Grammy
winner hinted at the breakup on her
era's tour setlist I would always like
to keep people on their toes on Saturday
E.T exclusively confirmed that the two
split a few weeks ago a source
explaining that the breakup was amicable
and not dramatic the relationship had
just run its course the source says
that's why Joe hasn't been spotted at
any of Taylor's shows I have to
understand that they're also really
heavy pressures that come with this life
and you just have to try to balance them
of course the singer is currently on
tour and some swifties think she alluded
to the breakup by switching up her
setlist during her show in Arlington
Texas on March 31st when I craft a song
and think about every aspect of it and
it comes together and then it goes out
in the world there are so many moving
pieces instead of Performing Invisible
String which is thought to be a love
song about her relationship with Joe
[Music]
invisible stream
she played the one a breakup track
[Music]
Taylor addressed the setlist switch up
on stage telling the crowd she enjoys a
good healthy setlist hijinks both songs
are off her 2020 album folklore where
Taylor and Joe famously collaborated
under the actor pseudonym William Bowery
William Bowery is Joe
as we know Taylor also played two
surprise songs at the show clean
[Music]
and death by a Thousand Cuts
both songs about heartbreak as a
songwriter there are times when you are
working harder to find the inspiration
and then there are those random
instances where it lands in front of
your face and all you have to do is grab
it Taylor's bestie Selena Gomez was in
the audience during the Arlington show
dancing and singing and showing her
support
oh
sell shared that clip on Instagram
writing in part proud to know you love
you forever and always I'm so proud of
her she'd do anything for me of course
Taylor and Joe started dating in 2016
and A source told E.T back in October
that the two were doing great and their
relationship was super strong Taylor's
done some acting too any chance you guys
would ever do anything together it's not
planned at the moment but who knows as
for Joe in 2018 he told British Vogue
that he knows Taylor's fans want to be
in the know when it comes to their love
but they intentionally kept a low
profile I think we have been
successfully very private and that has
now sunk in for people
[Music]
thank you